[Music]
i like your hair
thank you it's real fresh still like a
couple days ago yeah
i'm gonna say not today
[Music]
my name is davon taylor and i'm a
creative artist what's it like being
bisexual on dating apps
um i mean it's very overwhelming you
have lots more choices
i'm definitely a little bit pickier when
it comes to men
pretty boy rock star type is like very
focused in but um with women um i mean i
definitely have my types and stuff but
maybe not as specific
hello beautiful people
[Music]
hi
so is it my good go left
for no right for yes
[Music]
all right
we have a cute smile come over too
i must say not today but you're a cutie
still nonetheless
i love the hair love the tattoos we're
in similar realms
come on over i love the tuck
come on in
we had all sorts of style come on in i
think it's always nice when someone says
that you're like physically
appealing to them yeah it was nice it's
cute
[Music]
like the makeup job looks good
i'm gonna go not today
oh great smile come on in
[Music]
i like your hair thank you thank you
it's real fresh still like a couple days
ago yeah i'm gonna say not today
i got rejected it was cute though it's
fine you know
i like the hair i like the hair a lot i
would swipe right for sure
all right hi how are you i'm doing good
don't worry guys i want this part to be
over too this is like everybody's like
oh i'm saying not today hi i love the
color and the hair
come on in and last but not least
i like the hair like the chain say not
today
all right
you guys are all so hot though i love
you guys
we can still be friends i was like oh is
this gonna be like easier than doing
through a dating app
but like just like kind of have them
there and you like get the reactions in
real time it was like
more intimidating than i thought it was
going to be
all right what weapons did everybody
bring
joking we need the weapon
sorry i'm being a weirdo
i was like i was honestly i was like one
two three let's go
she goes out of here
bye all right
hello hello how's it going good
i feel like i'm on the bachelor what's
your name my name is darian
moon river fiorda my name is davon
vaughn nice to meet you
man look at those locks yeah i know
right i love the glass
me too man you have a very infectious
smile thank you you have
great style thank you oh it's that thing
people say like
you know if you die your ghost will be
wearing the same outfit you're wearing
all the time
damn that's something i don't think
about it right then i'm like i'm not
about to be a ghost wearing like
brush if someone's wearing crocs i'm so
sorry what do you do so i mostly work in
like internet content and stuff like
that i stream on twitch
uh seven days a week and i'm a musician
what kind of music do you do
something like melodic rap r b kind of
vibes i'm a realtor
i'm also a massage therapist i um have
recently gotten into like modeling if we
were gonna do a photo shoot what would
be the theme oh my god shadow play
shadow play what's your normal play um i
write for a horror movie website and
some screenplays and
want to make some movies did you just
recently get the green in
yeah i do different colors i love that
ramona flowers
okay wait what's your sign bro wait look
i want to guess though
are you taurus no oh what are you i'm a
gemini oh you're a gemini
you're a mellow gemini bro i know pisces
moon
we're not all crazy what's your son i'm
an aquarius
aquarius my best friend is an aquarius
oh there you go
okay so i feel all the vibes of your own
vibes honestly with like
dating apps i never have the best
experience so i just wanted to see how
it would be like face to face yeah i'm
not i'm not really the biggest fan of
dating apps
people might not put in the effort you
want them to put in
you know so it's like all right let's
cut the middle man out for this yeah
i see you got the tattoo and snail yeah
a necklace do you have any snakes uh no
i've actually never held one because i
don't know where to go to like there's
like little like reptile houses that's
what we're going on our first date
that's
thankful perfect okay okay tell me about
this one right here
it's a filipino vampire that's a fancy
word for it's the manananggal
when i was little i never really liked
myself or like
the culture i lived with
nowadays i've started to embrace who i
am and i got this tattoo to symbolize it
are you gay bisexual i'm bisexual so you
do think of it like a
spectrum percentage yeah i lean women
60 30. okay that's about where i'm at
tell me you are bisexual without telling
me you're bisexual
i fall in love with people's energy it's
always a vibe that makes me
understand what kind of feeling i'm
feeling even just sexually with someone
you use
vibe and energy in the same sentence and
that's very bisexual okay
tell me you're bisexual without telling
me you're bisexual
um i'm gay so you're gay
yeah okay did i win did you win
did you win for this round
well nice to meet you hallelujah bye
nice to meet you too have a great day
you too fiora
this is too much everybody's so cute
i think i know i think yeah
hey girl snaps for you
you're the winner picked me up i was
like feeling your brother
from the lineup i was like okay there's
some energy
i didn't want to say anything over there
to everyone else but i was like there's
some energy here you have such a like
gorgeous smile like
like yeah if we had a first date do you
smoke
i do smell yeah okay
ends up being like a real hang or
something
yeah i think he's attractive i mean
green air is a questionable choice but
nah
he he rocks it and he's got good energy
so
i want to you know like to see how
things go
awesome well awesome yeah of course
you did a good job man thank you thank
you everybody else for being here
give it up for yourselves
[Applause]
great shoe